والمراكز الاقليميه هادئه بشكل غير
اعتيادي لا هجمت صاروخيه او بطائرات مسيره
لروسيا منذ الثالث والعشرين من نوفمبر
الماضي على اكياس بحسب السي ان ان لكن ما
الاسباب
نفذت المسيرات الايرانيه التي تستخدمها
روسيا طلبت موسكو الفناء 1700 700 طائره
جديده او اكثر يؤكد المتحدث باسمي القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه لكن هما ذلك هناك امراض
الاول انك تستعدوا لي هجمات جديده عمده
المدينه ريتال يتحدث ويبدو انه هدوء ان
يصدق العاصفه الثاني هو انه هو رغم
الانخفاض الحاد في الهجمات على البنيه
التحتيه وشبكات الطاقه اوكرانيا لا تزال
تعانين من انقطاع الكهرباء الضربات
الروسيه كانت قويه للغايه اذا هدوئا سيجعل
الطرفين يستعدان المعارك وال توقفنا وربما
للشتاء دورا في ذلك وهنا موسكو تتهيا من
المرشح ان تقوم بنزع الرؤوس حربيه نوويه
من صواريخ كروز القديمه واستبدالها برؤوس
المعدنيه الثقيله لاستخدامها في قصف
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا تقييم
للاستخبارات العسكريه البريطانيه والسبب
استنزاف مخزون روسيا من الاسلحه بعيده
المدام ياخذنا هذا التوقع الى باب اخر خطر
كان لا ينقص العالم التطرق اليه الان
معاهده اليوستار بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا اتفاقا وقع في 2010 للحد من
الترسانه النوويه للقوتين
250 راس نوويه كلنا منهم معك حدا اقصى
بعيده جدا عن واقعه لسنتين مددت
الاتفاقيات في بدايه 2001 ل 5 سنوات اي
حتى
2026 لسوء الحظ المعاهده اقتحم مشهد
المهيمن في الحرب الاوكرانيه روسيا التي
تضع السلاح النووي خيارا لها على الطاوله
اجلت اجتماع مناقشه استئناف في عمليات
التفتيش بموجب المعاهده الولايات المتحده
من ناحيتها كانت متهيئه لكنها لم تتلقى
اجابه حقيقيه لتفسير اسباب التاجيل الروسي
بحسب جون كربي المتحدث باسمي
المجلس الامن القومي ربما فاتته تصريحات
كورد
[موسيقى]
اجواء والتصريحات تعيدنا بالزمن الى
الوراء الى الحرب البارده سباق التسلح
النووي كان جزءا كبيرا منها بالطبع
وللصدفه اليوم الثالث من ديسمبر هو ذكرى
اعلان الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جورج بوش
الاب والزعيم السوبياتي الراحل ميخائيل
غربه شوف انهاء الحرب البارده ونحن في عام
1989 في قمه مالطا سفينه الركاب
السوبييتيه مكسيم جورجي شاهده على الاعلان
التاريخي
ورغم اقتراح الامر في عهد رونالد ريجن لكن
جورج بوش الاب هو الذي وقع معاهده ستارت
مع الاتحاد السوفيتي للحد من الترسانه
النوويه في اخر يوم في شهر يوليو
1991 المفارقه انه في اليوم التالي
واين في اوكرانيا وعمه تحدث النزعه
القوميه نهايه الشهر
انهار الاتحاد السوفيتي
اللقاءات التي شهدت انها الحرب البارده
بين برج الاب وغربه شوف قد تتكرر اليوم او
السبيل انهاء حرب اوكرانيا
يؤكد انه مستعد للتحدث مع حوت لانهاء
الحرب
على الحوار بحسب الكربلائي بهذه البساطه
اذا كان الشرط هو مغادره موسكو لاوكرانيا
فالامر صعب وفي المقلب الاخر واشنطن لكن
من ناحيه زنسكي لن نضغط عليه للتفاوض يبدو
ان الهدوء الذي تحدثنا عنها فتحى المجال
لملفات عده